so there are a lot of people in DC who
are Democrats who probably don't really
want to be but if you don't vote in the
primaries that you're voting the
election doesn't really count in DC
because it is a one-party state it's not
even a two-party state hi I'm Nicolas be
with reason TV today we're talking with
Bruce majors Bruce is a Washington DC
realtor he ran for Congress from the
District of Columbia against a longtime
incumbent Eleanor Holmes Norton and won
a surprising 14,000 votes Bruce thanks
for talking with reason TV no problem
you're a longtime libertarian activist
you're a donor sometimes to the reason
foundation not profit that publishes us
were you surprised by your election
results you got somewhere in the
neighborhood of 14,000 votes which is
actually pretty strong yeah it was
pretty good at six percent during the
campaign I was so busy doing stuff like
hanging street signs and talking to
people and whatever that I actually
didn't have time to think about whether
we were going to have a strong showing
yeah I sort of thought that we would get
the minimum number which is 7500 it's
about half what we had that got that's
the number that's necessary for the LP
to get part about status right through
the 2016 alike that's right ok so you
you clear easily clear that her almost
doubled the amount that you need it is
there a room for a strong libertarian
movement in the DC local government or
in the from the congressional
representative I think stronger the most
libertarians probably felt there would
be I'm not sure it's going to come from
exactly any of the areas that were kind
of predicted I actually don't think that
the gay population will quickly start
voting libertarian any more than they
voted for independence Republicans i
think the gay population in DC are very
heavily lawyers lobbyists and federal
government employees and a lot of them
will just sort of vote their pocketbook
interest which means they'll probably
vote democrat or republican but i think
there are a lot of unrepresented kind of
working middle-class people in DC
including a lot of african americans who
are traditionally you know vote heavily
level 8 dumb do you see is a one-party
state so you have to register democrat
to have an effective voice in the
primaries because they're closed
primaries so there are a lot of people
in DC who are Democrats who
don't really want to be but if you don't
vote in the primaries that you're voting
the election doesn't really count in DC
because it is a one-party state it's not
even a two-party state so but you're
saying that there are a lot of
african-americans who are not really
being who know they're not being served
well I met through the campaign
including some people who were
libertarians as long as I've been and
just so happened in african-american
woman whose realtor who've been
libertarian since there were teenagers
who actually hadn't met until they
started showing up at campaign events
but I think there a lot of people I met
a lot of people in DC who are upset
because DC voted by a two-to-one margin
and it was over half in every single
board including you know every board
ethnically economically for term limits
in the mid 90s and the City Council just
decided to nullify this referendum that
passed by sixty-six percent and I met a
lot of people who remember that who are
like really upset that we don't have
term limits I don't think the Democrats
are going to give it to them the
republican party in DC is actually
slightly libertarian it's the only state
republican party that has gay marriage
in its state platform but it's also kind
of ineffective and it might actually be
that the libertarian party can be at
least as big as they are even slightly
bigger in a very short time well thank
you Bruce majors Bruce managers DC area
realtor and an unsuccessful but
surprisingly powerful candidate for
Congress from Washington DC thanks for
talking to us for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
you